-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with John Oliver.
John, I've always
appreciated over the years
that if you text me
about something we've done
on the show, it is something
that no one else has liked
or commented on.
I felt that way about your
long-running Adam Driver bit
that came to a wonderful
conclusion with Adam Driver.
-Yeah. Yes.
-Can you just talk us
from the beginning of it,
the seeds of where it started,
to the conclusion of getting
the real Adam Driver?
-Yeah, the seed --
the initial seed was,
you know, one of our writers
writing a very weird joke
out of absolutely nowhere.
And then the water on that see
was, back when we had
an audience in March,
feeling real resistance
from the audience at the joke.
It felt like they
about 40% enjoyed it.
And it logged in my head -
"Oh, let's try
and do this again."
So we did it as a callback
a few weeks later,
and they weren't really happ
to have it back.
And so at that point, it becam
something of an obsession
in our staff.
And a few months into the bit,
we kind of -- we broke it.
One of the writers had written
something kind of saying,
"I don't know if he even -
It doesn't seem like
he would enjoy this one.
It could be over."
That was as much of a ribbon
as it felt we could put on it.
So at that point,
we reached out to him and said
"I don't know if you know
what we've been doing.
There's no easy way
into this conversation.
We've been making some comment
about you,
and would you hypothetically
be interested
in responding towards
the end of the year?"
And the message came back
from him saying
he has heard about it, he thinks
it's very strange, and he's in
So I thought, "Oh, great."
So we didn't know what we were
going to do, but at least
we knew at that point
that we had an end in sight.
And, yeah, as it turned out,
what the end in sight was
was him calling into the sho
and explaining the ways in which
he was going to demolish me.
-It was also -- Watching i
is a real reminder that
Adam Driver is a terrific actor.
-Unbelievably good.
I couldn't see him.
I was doing it --
I could only hear him,
and it wasn't until
I watched it back, you think
"Oh, [bleep]. Look at him!
Look at him doing acting,
as I'm giving him nothing back."
Like, he's literally performin
in front of a tennis ball.
That's the equivalent of wha
he's getting back from me.
And he's doing such good acting.
-Yeah.
-At a point where
it really was not required
but he was really
flexing muscles.
-Yeah. It was a case -- An
I say this as a fan of yours
When you guys
were on the split screen,
it was very hard to imagin
anyone was watching you.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't be 100% confident
it was there.
It was -- Every part
of that juxtaposition
is [bleep] brutal.
-Yeah.
-Acting ability, physically.
Let's not lie.
Put those two things together,
and it barely seems like
the same species -- barely
-You've come here before.
You were on the show
before Thanksgiving in the past.
And, unfortunately,
you can't be here live,
so you missed
getting to see the tree.
I know how you love stuff
like trees.
-Yeah. I love it.
-Holiday trees.
-One of the things I like
the most, actually, is that --
Are you still being tortured
by that Christmas music
going 'round and 'round
at 30 Rock?
Is that still going?
-No, because that was for
the ice-skating rink.
So we're actually --
It's not -- It's very un--
-That's a shame. I've always
enjoyed the kind of --
the muffled killing-spree musi
outside of your office
for basically 3 1/2 weeks.
-The tree got off
to a bad start.
I'm sure you saw this photo.
When it went up,
it was as though they aske
for, like, a discount tree
'cause no one was coming
this year.
It looks better now,
but I kind of wish --
Don't you wish it was that
-It's a huge mistake.
They should have left it
like that.
I was so happy.
When they unveiled it
and it just started wiltin
and stuff fell off,
I thought, "Yes! That's right.
Is it the tree we want? No
Is it the tree we deserve?
Absolutely.
Emphatically, yes, it is.
They should have
just hung one string
with, like, lights
broken across --
-Yeah, or put it
right against 30 Rock
and, like, turned it aroun
so you couldn't see
the [bleep] side.
-Or just lent it on the ground
and put a giant garbage ba
half around it.
[ Laughter ]
That's -- That --
I just think that would have
been a more fun tree because n
one wants a good tree right now,
do they?
-Yeah.
-Do you think people
want to live a lie?
Come on.
-Yeah, it was the bad-tree year,
I agree.
Congratulations.
Your first Thanksgiving
as an American citizen, John
-Yes, yes.
-I'm assuming it's going to be
a muted affair?
-Oh, yeah. That's right. Yeah.
There's not much going on.
But as a new American,
I'm already pushing the realit
of what Thanksgiving is abou
further and further down.
I'll forget about it next year
[ Laughter ]
-I expect nothing less from you.
Hey, this is no surprise.
As always,
it's a pleasure talking to you
-You too.
-Happy Thanksgiving.
Happy holidays.
Thanks for being here, buddy
-It is an absolute pleasure.
See you soon -- maybe.
Back to quarantine.
It's going to be a while.
I won't see you soon.